Joe Hakem freedom a history of us what's
it all about just as the title says it's
about its it's about us our story our
our search for freedom the the American
quest the American dream when did all
this start I mean the books yeah this
book itself what's it well I started
with a 10 volume series for young
readers and that's called a history of
us and and I mean my passion is is
teaching is reaching kids and I think
we've done a poor job of that and in
telling our story and we're historically
illiterate as a nation so those books
are out there kids are reading them some
adults are reading them and out of that
came a television series and our
television series came a need for a book
for for families for older readers and
so that's what the freedom book is about
I must say I'm drowning in information
from acidic sitting here on the table is
this and we'll show it on the screen
just a second ten volumes where did this
come from well it started out I was just
going to write a US history for kids it
was going to be one volume and I have a
writing style I tell stories it's a
narrative history and storytelling takes
a little more time than a straight
recitation of facts it's kind of you
know you sit in a rocking chair and tell
stories to kids and you you take your
time so the book started it it just
began to grow and the one volume
suddenly I thought well it's going to be
two volumes and then four volumes and it
ended up as ten and I worked it out with
kids actually in classrooms and we
decided that's kind of an optimal size
they're small books i want to tell you
identity all this along the side or my
little markings to show things that are
in the books themselves what years in
school the kids read these books my
intention i I focused on 10-year olds
which is fifth grade and that's when we
teach you as history and that was my
target audience and I and I work these
out in classrooms in fifth grades and I
actually paid 10 year olds to be my
editors I gave a manuscript I get
them a code I said you know right be4
boring in the mat in the manuscript if
people every kid knows that word and and
so was ten year olds that I worked with
the books actually are being used from
third grade they're being used in a
number of AP 11th grades that they've
astonished me but I came out of
journalism and you know anybody who can
read the newspaper can read these books
where did you start your own education
about history well I hated history like
it like most kids it was dull in school
and I went to I grew up in rutland
vermont and i kind of missed US history
i think or at least i don't remember it
very much but when I got to college I
had a professor David Donald who's
well-known American history a great
Civil War scholar and he taught
something called intellectual history
and I couldn't imagine what was
intellectual about history until I had
mr. Donald and it was great and and and
that got me excited and since then I
delved into history when did you start
in journalism um I in elementary school
I think I started writing for the school
newspaper and I've always that involved
with journalism in one way or another I
was a reporter for the virginian-pilot
in Norfolk and I became the first woman
to be an editorial writer and I spent
years as a journalist where did you
start to teach aight i got a master's
degree in education after i went to
smith college and then afterwards I got
a master's degree in education from
goucher and my first job was a special
teaching special ed middle school
students in Syracuse New York and then I
taught in Omaha taught in Virginia Beach
and and so I've had a I have a limited
attention span I seem to teach different
to have taught different ages and I like
that what do you live now we live we
have a house in Virginia Beach and an
apartment in Denver they have
grandchildren and Denver
so what did you do and these books for
the students that had never been done
before if you remember your school
history books the pretty dull and most
school history books are litanies
effects and the idea that history is
considered dull it's just astonishing I
mean history isn't dull history is its
stories its adventures it does it's a
natural with kids and that we've made it
does it's just incredible and so I've
told stories I've made this narrative
out I've also this the way we teach we
need to radically change our schools for
the information age but the way we
taught history is by making it a watered
down version of adult history and kids
are not water down to tell us they're a
different breed of fish and and we yeah
and I I studied the educational
psychologists I am I thought a lot about
it I worked with kids and i wrote for
children rather than adults there's an
Educational Psychologist Kieran Egan
he's at he's a Canadian is it Simon
Fraser University and he talks about the
stages the kids go through and from four
to eight there in the mythic stage and
that's when they believe in Giants when
they believe in the Santa Claus women
you know that they and that's a
wonderful time to teach classic
mythology and our social studies
curricula and in that stage when kids
want things larger than life any one
thing I want Giants you know we we have
we teach them about the neighborhood
grocer we teach them about the fireman
you just dull we have we have something
in our schools called expanding horizons
you start with the neighborhood and then
you you know you grow to the the city
and then the state and then and then the
world it's it's just it hasn't worked
and that's one of the reasons we don't
know history so I just threw that out
and anyway after the mythic stage ship
to the Florida eight you go into
something called the romantic stage and
that's 8 to 14 and those are my victims
and that's when you suddenly realize
that maybe there are giants except for
basketball players and and your but you
don't want to give up I hope you want
heroes and and there are giants on the
earth they and they are real and and
they're heroes and those the people that
I've emphasized in our our our standard
history books don't and and so in well
in writing about the Civil War instead
of focusing on the horrors have I bring
those in but I also you focus on the
Harriet Tubman the people who were
giants in you know when you're mean I I
to be wells is a heroic figure she wrote
about lynching I mean and she risked her
life you know most of the books focus on
those the pictures of people hanging
from trees you know I I have those but I
didn't my emphasis is on an era that's
what my kids want I want to read a
statement that you made on page 10 of
your first book in the introduction you
say i believe the united states of
america is the most remarkable nation
that has ever existed no other nation in
the history of the world has ever
provided so much freedom so much justice
and so much opportunity to so many
people that is a big statement you don't
have to agree with it you're telling the
students arguing with the books theme is
okay yeah the first class that i have
this my manuscript out in seven cities
before it was published and i got
feedback from kids and the first teacher
who used it was a little hostile to a
whole idea of just using a manuscript no
pictures at that point nothing and she
was completely won over by her reaction
for kids to that paragraph she said they
were just blown away no one had ever
told them that you didn't have to agree
with the book i mean they just you know
if it's printed it it's you know seems
to be decreed from the heavens and and
and we know books make mistakes and I
keep telling kids that over and over
again history is fluid you know it's
it's not set in stone what about this
statement because if you read it you've
got 2073 pages in these ten
and if you read through this you hear a
lot of things about America that isn't
very pretty but you say here i believe
the united states is the most remarkable
nation that's ever existed i really
believe that i think we have a heritage
that's fantastic we have great documents
we have this go liberty and justice for
all I mean we're you know we're never
going to get there but it is a great
goal we're not you know where people
were not any different than people
anywhere else we're not special people
but we we do have this American Dream we
don't hear about the Chinese dream or
the German dream you know we had but
people all over the world know what you
mean when you say the American dream so
yeah I'll stick with that statement it's
I've had some static from it you you
have had I mean some people accuse me of
talking of American exceptionalism and I
don't think where we as people aren't
exceptional but our goals are I believe
now in the backyard almost always have a
note from the author what's the purpose
behind that um I think that readers like
something personal they like and so I
thats those are just little comments in
which the readers get to know me and I
talk a little bit about myself and I get
I hundreds of letters from kids I think
that most textbooks don't you don't
generate that and you know I talk I
write to them personally and they answer
back one of the things on this page I
want to ask you guys or about the
teachers and educators and friends who
encouraged me or about the people at the
american federation of teachers and the
smithsonian institution who believed in
this project any concern that the union
endorses this book no I just had I had
some wonderful people who helped me out
shanker was one of them I could started
I didn't have any money he gave me some
some judge some freelance writing jobs
and he and he just encouraged me and and
the AFT has has done that right along
what is the Smithsonian have to do with
it Smithsonian would they were
enormously helpful getting with the
information and they were very excited
about what I was doing and they went
over all the manuscripts they checked
facts they
help you get information what you know
I'm not I've had fabulous people helping
me I'm not competing with the academics
I don't pretend to do that I see myself
as a pop writer I want to get the word
of history and the wonders of history
out there and and then I hope that a
general public writer and then I hope
people will go on beyond what I've done
and and read the academics want to keep
mentioning for folks that are watching
that there are 10 books that cost
roughly how much a piece they I think
the the paperbacks are fourteen dollars
or so they're they're much cheaper if
you buy them in quantity for the
classroom movement something like a
hundred dollars if you buy all of them
together one time right but when moving
back and forth between the single volume
and the single volume which is connected
with the television show the forward has
an endorsement basically from george w
bush and from a lady Laura Bush how'd
you get that the the TV producer they
introduced the TV show and so of the TV
producer got that and it's very exciting
is there anybody that doesn't like this
format or the way you teach history um
there's a ver I've been banned in
chiefland Florida because some some
parent objected and the superintendent
of schools said that he didn't want any
books in schools that have opinions all
books have opinions whether whether
they're you know this is because this is
because I'm talking to my reader it's
obvious that there's a person behind it
how often do you give your opinion I not
that often in the books but I always
when I there's always a caveat with it
that um this is my opinion you must read
somebody else I'm Kate constantly tell
kids that but no I work very hard to
what I try and do is give varied
opinions of every so that during the
Revolutionary War I have the British the
British press describing a battle and I
have an American econo account of the
same battle and they're quite different
I want I want kids to understand that
history is is his opinion it's one side
thinking about something versus
other side think you know it's just as
today we're often disagree and you and I
could see the same event maybe and write
about it from it from different
perspectives okay the first of these
books by Joe hakem came out what year
again 93 and the last one was published
when we just have a new edition and it
includes 911 so it just came out you
know you go back to the original book
and you talk about me the meaning you
and you say that well this was going on
I got married to Sam your husband what's
he do he's now retired he was a
businessman and and then you talk about
you have three children Ellen Jeffrey
and Daniel and Ellen played some big
role in all this yeah Ellen's I was
taught history in high school and the
teacher took the textbook and and gave
it to the kids backwards I think book
was so dull he was trying to do
something different i hadn't liven it up
but it was you know she didn't learn any
history history is it builds on itself
and you can't teach it that way so i was
horrified by the fact that she didn't
know any in history when she graduated
from high school and that was part of
what got me started where r Ellen and
Jeffrey and Daniel today and are they
all interested in history I I don't have
put them on the spot Ellen is in Denver
and that's why we lived there most of
the year and she's a marketing whiz and
she has been married to todd johnson
who's a landscape architect and they
have two kids Natalie and Sam who are
our grandchildren Jeff is a professor at
American University and math professor
and married to hire Berman who's a
speech pathologist and Jeff and Danny
the youngest is an New York Times
reporter he's the Detroit bureau chief
and he just he and his wife Lyz just had
a new baby our newest grandson k see if
you go to the second volume and I'm page
on nine there's a chapter here 29 on Ben
Franklin the reason i picked this out is
because somewhere in one of these books
you say that Ben Franklin is your
favorite American I don't know a favor
it is the word and I
think that's the word but ultimate kind
of no no in many ways because he
combined energy and a business sense and
a dedication to what we call American
values he's a great great American
favorite maybe isn't my word but I I'm
intrigued with the guy do you find
others at when you do when you teach in
the classroom the kids have favorites
yeah well I pulled out this character
that that most Americans don't know
william johnson who was in the French
and Indian War and Johnson came to this
country as from Ireland and as a poor
boy came to upstate New York and met his
neighbors who were Mohawk Indians and
learned the Mohawk language became was
adopted into a mohawk tribe became the
richest American of his time or maybe
the second richest deuce it was kind of
a William Gates and controlled the the
fur trade and he lived in two worlds
successfully when he was an Indian he
dressed in Indian garb he spoke Indian
languages and he was it was an Indian
and when he was an Englishman he put on
his English outfit and he was a very
rich Englishman and is a really decent
human being the English would not have
won the french and indian war with that
william johnson he was one of only two
Americans overnighted by the English
colonial Americans a pretty terrific guy
and written out of the history books
because he broke the mores of his time
he married an Indian woman and he you
know he lived with Indians so he's kind
of a favorite kids love him they do and
you see it early and do me teach him
early yeah yeah he's as he said French
and Indian War III right a he was a very
successful general he died in 1775 if he
had not died him might have competed
with George Washington for the
generalship during the yeah the
revolution now one of the other things
you do is that these little side bars
are these your responsibilities are
there yeah yeah they are the I started
out with notes footnotes and I had
actually drawn a little foot with a note
and that would they were going to be at
the bottom of each page and the kids who
were reading the manuscript before it
was published we're just so fascinated
with those footnotes that they started
growing
and to kind of life of their own and
books are kind of interactive the way
yeah you know TV the internet computers
are today and and it works with kids
this the note here says do you use the
expression I'm stumped when you're stuck
about what to do or think in the days
when west bound wagons traveled terrible
roads like this one where tree stumps
stuck out of the ground if you hit a
stump you were in trouble colon stumped
and then there you have a I do yeah I do
a lot with words and what makes me
different from the traditional books for
kids history books is that they usually
have limited vocabularies kids love big
words and we all like big words their
empower and you feel smart you have a
big word so I use lots of big words but
I am I explain them do you know why buck
is another word for dollar it's because
in the days of Daniel Boone and the long
hunters of buckskin was worth about a
dollar so the money was named for the
deer that it bought yeah i mean the
words have stories everything as stories
and and that's and you'll remember your
number things if you tie them to stories
so I an etymology is it's fun here's the
issue from the colonies to country 1735
to 1791 why that title that was the time
when we changed from a colonial nation
into a into the United States did you as
you wrote these books were they
published and then no I had nine and a
half books finished before I got a
publisher it was crazy i don't know how
i kept kept going but i somehow i did
nine and before now how many publishers
you talk to everybody they all turned me
down yeah if there's a publisher out
there who didn't turn me down i offer my
apologies for not giving them a chance
it just just no because they seem to
break the mold i mean one publishers
suggested that i make it sound more
textbook e um you know and why oxford
why would well well at a certain point
and these books were out i was testing
them in classrooms and and I was getting
this fabulous response so I knew I had
something and but I was kind of
discouraged and I ran into an old friend
who's a his
Dorian Paul Nagel and he was telling him
my sad story and he said there's a man
in New York if anyone can help you it's
buyer in hollinshead so I sent the
manuscript to him Byron had been
president of Oxford and also of American
heritage and he eventually took the he
had a hard time actually getting the
publish but he eventually took them to
Oxford and they had never published
children's books in this country before
and they were just getting started and
so the idea of a ten book series appeal
to them as a starter and were they the
first publisher to buy it or somebody
else put it out early no no Oxford
expert did and you call them oup yeah
Oxford University publish right what's
the way what's is there any irony here
that the British company well actually
when I went to England and talk to some
of the people at Oxford over there they
said they refer to this series as a
history of them so yeah I don't know
visit my earning their but um and you're
calling in a history of US history of us
I want to read this from chapter 30 of
your third volume and it just to show
how you do it differently there just
isn't room in this book to tell you
about the first submarine built in
America or that it was tested during the
American Revolutionary War if you want
to know about it you have to find the
story on your own if you've been reading
carefully you'll know the name of the
inventor how often do you tell the
reader hey and got room for you go find
it yourself I do it all the time I I
mean we're in the learning the
information i use the 21st century and
we want to get kids to do research and I
constantly tell them that this book is
even though it's 10 books it's still
over the surface there's lots and lots
more to do I always tell teachers you
know tell your kids that the author it
anguishes overall she had to leave out
so have your children write more
chapters and I want to get them out
they're researching and writing I mean
that's that's the goal in the back of
the book again the note from the author
exact imaging is the first are the first
two words up here exact imagine I'm
sorry exact imagining its again
television but
what's that mean well that's what that's
a definition of history history is exact
imagining that that isn't my definition
but I go on to tell about it and i think
that's that's a pretty nifty yeah way to
think about history that it's not it's
not dull facts it's its interpretations
it's it's exact but it's imaginative who
would disagree with that I don't know
how but it soon the textbook authors are
fair I mean we see history and something
that's dull and static and once you have
it it's it's finished and it's always
it's the imaginative look at you know
search and interpretation that's
interesting there's a lot of talk also
in the back of the books about mapping
cardin cartography and on this
particular page you say which brings me
to a good word for you to note
gerrymandering gerrymandering I know it
okay Gary yeah get it both way an Elvis
Jerry you go on to explain who it was
but the interesting thing here that I
hadn't seen before you say that Gilbert
Stuart the artist who painted George
Washington again and again notice the
shape of one newly created district and
being an artist decorated it with wings
and claws it looked like a salamander
that animal combine the with Jerry's
name made a new piece that was labeled a
gerrymander or gerrymander what's the
reason for all the reference in the back
of these books to the maps oh I mean you
can't understand history without knowing
where you are so again geography is
something that we've denied our kids and
not making internet making is so
interesting and there's so many stories
that go with it and now here's a map for
instance in the ban you see this in a
lot of the listen all the back of all
the books um they're slightly different
but but yeah there is a little Atlas in
the back of each book and you shall hear
the original 13 colonies your original
United States the Louisiana Purchase
seated by Mexico 1845 the Oregon Country
how hard is it to get kids to understand
this
I think you just give it to them again
and again and you know just as we don't
teach the multiplication tables once you
you give them maps of all kinds and and
and these books are just to start with
that making the mat making is just so
interesting the more we can get kids to
look at maps to to get a sense of a
place you in this the new nation 1789 to
1850 you talk about see if I can find it
here Lafayette is here but you also talk
about the fellow that took his name the
boy james Armistead Lafayette do you
remember the story of that yeah he was
he was a slave who was a spy and for the
Americans and after the war begin was
freed and a pretty terrific guy and
what's interesting about him is he was
very bright very engaging and the
British fell for his he went into the
British camps and sold supplies to them
and then came back and told the
Americans what were what was going on
after the war he was he was freed and
given some land and then he was a black
man who hired slaves who bought slaves
and so he became a slave owner and I
think that a lot of people don't
understand that slavery was an economic
issue if you wanted to prosper you had
to have slaves in that southern economy
and so there were there were some 12,000
slaves owned by free blacks at the time
of the Civil War it's a small number but
still significant you say though that
when the Marquis de Lafayette came back
for the big tour of the United States in
1824 he this is these two hooked up yes
they were big friends and it's just
wonderful it's a wonderful story it's
kind of heartwarming now where did you
find something like that history books
my kids are always asking me where I
found things in books kids I go to the
library all the time and so I rely on
the great historians and all of my books
were read in manuscript by top
historians by almost always every with
every book more than one James McPherson
read the
civil war book in the reconstruction
book in manuscript he pointed out some
errors to me I changed on that it's just
me nor I'm enormously important to me to
have experts I mean I come at this from
a journalist point of view and so I'm
used to going to experts I'm doing
science books now and I have some
fabulous physicist who who are reading
my manuscript and are so helpful who
else had to read your or did read your
history books uh James axtell read the
first one just trying to think the phone
Nagel do any of that no I don't think he
did he's he's really had Oh Bernie
wiesberger who has written he some keeps
grand sweep histories was it was very
helpful I had conservatives liberals we
just we had the spectrum of people and
having Oxford as a publisher it gave me
access to some fine historians and Byron
thought anyway a lot of people read it
they also and they didn't agree
necessarily which you know I had to deal
with here's Robert Carter the third and
the reason I picked him was because of
the Golden Rule yeah I like that story
you have here on page 145 of your let's
see this is 1789 the golden rule what's
the story um well that's first of all
kids need to know what the golden rule
is everyone used to know that but they
don't but but he was a really
interesting guy part of the Carter
Family the richest Virginia family an
enormously wealthy man when Jefferson
was broke he went to Carter for a loan
so this man who had many plantations he
freed all of his slaves that was just an
unbelievable act his his kids wanted
nothing to do with him he I mean he
enraged everyone but he had the courage
to to free his slaves out of conviction
he was very religious he was searching
for meaning in life he actually tried
several religions interesting guy and
interesting issues for kids to grapple
with I mean we assume that kids can't
talk about profound things and they can
then you get into some presidents and
then you use another tech
increase say the first seven presents
are easy but how are you going to
remember presents 8 through 15 these are
your choices one forget them worst
choice to say them over and over okay
choice three find a memory system and
remember them easily best choice what is
a memory system these know mama mnemonic
devices where you you get a sentence
when the first the first letter tells
you the name of a president or whatever
you want to remember so in this case in
order to remember Van Buren Harrison
Tyler Polk Taylor Fillmore Pierce and
Buchanan you have the sentence very
heavy tennis players throw fast purple
balls right you know I'm trying to help
kids anyway I can does it work doesn't
work terribly well for me but it seems
to work for others and here is a
silhouette game kind of an audience
sought to try to get it close up with
that see whether or not they could
figure out from a silhouette who these
presents are we move that over yeah it's
a little closer to it there how often
you do things like this I just we just
have lots of gimmicks and fun things for
kids and even some riddles and I had a
hard time I mean books have a lot of
humor and that's missing from textbooks
and getting publishers to appreciate
that kids have a love love jokes love
love games should seem obvious I I did
okay on this except for one I got Martin
Van Buren and John Tyler and John Quincy
Adams but this was a stumper I don't
even know who that is it's early aight
william henry harrison oh ok went around
right along yeah he's not he's got one
of the great um he's in he's on the list
do the kids I know you should call them
kids or not but to the young people that
use these books do they end up having a
favorite president oh they they all
first of all they all want to know who
my favorite president is
I am I hope they do what do you have in
yinz I guess Abraham Lincoln oh it's
it's hard to get immersed in US history
and that love lakeland what is it do you
like about Lincoln I love the fact that
he grew so much that he was like you
know person who just had a wonderful
mind and ask questions and was
thoughtful and cared about ish people
and issues and he's pretty wonderful
this painting got my attention and that
one of your further books it's a Samuel
FB Morris painting and you point out in
here that first you ask people to find
the Mona Lisa and our Cameron get close
but the Mona Lisa's right there and then
you say this is Morris himself who was
he what is this painting and what do you
try to teach with this well you'd be
surprised how many kids don't even know
what the Mona Lisa is and and I you know
I think we need to become generalists we
need to have rich you need to have our
kids have rich backgrounds and ask
questions and go on beyond their Samuel
FB Morse was a an inventor besides being
an artist he's just a really a
renaissance man interesting guy can you
tell the story of nakayama man zero you
remember that one yeah a Japanese boy in
America um yeah he was the he wanted to
go back to he had a Japanese ancestry
and he got on a no way that he's a guy
there are two stories there well he's
the guy that got shipwrecked and was
picked up by a an American whaling ship
taken to New England and he came
eventually a sailor and a captain and
it's pretty interesting a lot of what I
saw the books I'd seen for the first
time yeah do you get that comment I'll
get it I even get it from a lot of
professional historians because I go for
quirky things I go for if you know I
have a main story that yeah but you have
to tell obviously you know can't leave
at George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
but that's the quirky things that appeal
to me and usually
a deeper meaning it's it's over and
again I I'm impressed with how many
ordinary Americans make a difference all
right here's that we see which book this
is this is 1855 to 1865 breaking the law
a discussion of ethics what are you
trying to get at here I'm trying to get
into deep conversations with kids I want
them to think about ethical issues you
know it's more than history is a whole
lot more than facts if it's just facts
forget it but its its consideration of
you know real issues I do two pages on
lying and presidential lying and in the
name of national security in the name of
covering up personal behavior there
isn't a kid who hasn't struggled with
the issue of lying of telling a fib and
I want I want them to talk about it and
ethics yeah one teacher told me that she
spends a week of us that ethics using
that as a starting point when the kids
use these books in the classroom how
much of it do they read for each class
you know I don't you know they're very
flexible because they're different books
and they're used differently one of the
things that kind of disturbs me I mean
I'm happy you know if you want my books
use them any way that you want that's
just up to you but I find a lot of
teachers extract chapters and we'll take
it we'll take a book and maybe read
three or four chapters from the book and
pull them out of context and our kids we
have a literacy problem in this country
and when we when we when we talk about
literacy and we talk about teaching
reading we usually talk about fiction
and nonfiction is is the reading form of
our time it's the you know it's the
Information Age kind of reading you read
nonfiction very differently than you
read fiction Union i read with a pencil
and we need to teach that and we don't
in most of our schools and the idea that
these are whole books so that you start
at the beginning and and you know read
and that one chapter builds on another
escapes a lot of teachers and so this a
lot of teachers they're teaching a unit
on immigration they'll pull out chapters
or paragraphs on information on
immigration that bothers me want to go
back to your breaking the law discussion
of ethics because you do something in
here that you see periodically
not in most history books you say I have
an answer to this dilemma of the evil
law but before I tell you my thoughts
come up with the answers of your own
then see if we agree you are entitled to
your own opinion ok here is my opinion
fine and you say government under law is
the only reasonable form of government
in our complex world so it is important
that citizens respect the law you go on
to say but suppose the unjust law
doesn't get changed then sometimes for
some people the best course is to break
the law explain that well Martin Luther
King is the certainly a prime example of
that a man who believed in in issues
believe that that segregation was wrong
and even and where there were laws that
enforced segregation he decided to break
those laws but he was very conscious of
the fact that he was breaking a law and
that he had to pay a penalty which meant
going to jail which he did we have other
thorough did that went to jail rather
than pay taxes to support the Mexican
War which he didn't believe in that's
that takes a lot of courage I think the
whole idea of passive resistance kids
have to understand that it takes more
courage to to quietly resist a law than
to you know hit out with punches are you
know guns or whatever on the back flaps
of all these books there's something I
what would you call this in the end
pages yeah just the end pages but
there's a lot of information on those
images and this is one the economies of
the north and south circa 1860 and if we
can get in closer here on this down this
whole row you compare the union with a
Confederate and everything from the
population where you show that the union
was two and a half times larger than the
Confederates free male population aged
60 18 to 60 years old it was four point
four to one free men and military
service forty-four percent in the north
ninety percent in the South wealth
produced three to one in favor of the
north railroad mileage two point four to
one there isn't a category here that I
can remember that the South didn't it
wasn't really behind the north
so what do you learn from that what is
what are the young people learn from
this what did we adults like um well you
know the you can be behind it from N and
win a war and the South maybe should
have won the war if you if you look at
the revolution I mean we were behind
England and everything but we believed
in our cause and we one of the Vietnam
War is the same thing I mean little
Vietnam was certainly couldn't compare
to you know the great American nation
and yet they won the war and that those
statistics are just interesting I mean
they provoke discussion here is
reconstructing America 1865 to 1890 this
is another issue and inside here you
have law and the ladies like that one
what's it about lady they laws laws were
again us women in the particularly in
the 19th century and for half of the
20th century and it's I tell the story
of some women who went ahead and did
their own thing Belva Lockwood who went
to law school and and and then couldn't
practice and wrote a letter to the
President and said Ulysses Grant and
said you know he was head of the
National University in Washington which
doesn't exist anymore and he said she
said if you're at the head of this
university then then you've got to allow
me to have a law degree in practice if
you're not taking name off the hit that
yeah the letterhead this particular
section starts with Myra Colby Bradwell
passed the Illinois Bar Exam that meant
she knew everything a lawyer was
required to know but it was eighteen
sixty nine and the Illinois Supreme
Court said she could not practice law
for one reason it it thought important
she was a woman bradwell took her case
to the US Supreme Court that court
agreed with Illinois declaring quote the
paramount destiny and mission of women
are to fulfill the noble and benign
offices of wife and mother this is the
law of the Creator unquote that is from
there yes Supreme Court yeah and
actually in
in the later books you're gonna find
stuff like that cup is in the 1950s we
are still saying writing stuff like that
did you know this before you got into
the study of olive no part of I think
that the what I do is because it's so
exciting to there's a g-wiz quality in
these books and it's because I was
discovering things and the more you get
into a subject the more you're inclined
to think everybody knows that and and so
I like writing about things that I don't
know how a lot out you know discovering
and then vicariously passing that on to
my readers same book on page 176 you say
here is a personal confession I have
fallen in love with George Washington
club yeah hi I mean I I share my
passions but then you go on to say so
i'm a bit annoyed there isn't room for a
chapter about him but this book is long
enough maybe it's for the best now
you'll have to find out about him on
your own i am the more the best way to
learn is to do it for yourself and so
the more i can provoke kids to to go on
themselves by the way these books have
spawned some absolutely fabulous
teaching materials which were done
independently at johns hopkins
university a something called the talent
development team there it was using the
books and at-risk schools and they have
done six hundred and fifty pages per
book of teaching materials that's some
of that's available the rest of it is
coming out from oxford and it's just
incredible stuff is all this available
through Oxford publishing through Oxford
yeah and there's also a teaching a
website which goes with the the freedom
book but applies to the other books also
and and that you can just download it's
through PBS and then you put in freedom
a history of us and it's fabulous
teaching materials how often do you have
adults tell you that they're reading
here a lot of adults reiterated and it's
it's a it's sort of a quick read in
American history it's and it's a good
way I'm writing for for newcomers to US
history or those who forgotten and one
want to start and then you can go on to
Joseph Ellis or David McCullough I want
to go to 192 page in this particular
volume where you talk about linkage
seeing the links between them helps you
see a better picture and you're talking
about a woman named Frances gauge
because she played a very she played a
link role and you explain that was
Sojourner Truth and you say so often we
don't hear about people like Francis
gage yeah Fanny gage aunt Fanny they
called her she was a very important
woman in her time and she's just
interesting but she introduced Sojourner
Truth you say cheese yeah she was she
was hit at a conference where so during
the famous conference where sojourners
truth got up in an today and I am a
woman um and she was in charge and and
and she was kind of a an important force
in her time knew everybody in the
women's movement by the way how much how
many of these have sold four million
copy of books that sold individual boom
individual books at least smaller how
about the big one how's that dying the
freedom um I don't know that hasn't been
out long haven't told me yet and do you
know how many people will buy the set
the whole set at one time I don't I
don't the the a lot of school systems
use five books in one grade and then
five but like my favorite is in Virginia
they've used five books and fifth grade
and five books and sixth grades so it's
a two-year sequence we used to teach try
and teach us history all in one year and
what happens is nobody gets through it
and more and more schools or our states
are going to two-year sequences which
makes sense is there a place apart part
of the night States uses he's more than
others seems to be mostly they've sold a
word of mouth and so they're clusters
where are those clothes out michigan
there i think there are a lot of people
in california on the East Coast their
eyes seem to have a lot of fans any
aversion denied us in the south I don't
think so I mean well as they say that
Miss Florida town is
ban me but not as far as I know all
right in the volume 1882 1917 there was
a map that got my attention I mean it
just seemed to be very instructive and
this is immigration and for a hundred
years from 1820 to 1920 and what you
show on here is how many people from
what countries immigrated to the United
States and you can start here by seeing
Russia had three million 250,000 came to
the United States in those years 2
million I'm were Jews now you have a
there's a Jewish background and an
immigrant background and you talk about
this in in your book she tell us the
story about everybody talk about your
family and where did they come from in
the world well my grandfather was it was
an orphan in Russia and very very poor
even by immigrant Jewish standards I
mean he had no parents and he 19 leaving
behind a wife and baby left Russia came
to New York got on a barge going up the
Hudson River and shoveling coal I think
he probably had muscles he got off at
troy new york and started walking and
ended up in Glens Falls and became a
peddler and eventually a very prominent
citizen he was illiterate and I didn't
find that out he was very very
successful he owns lots of businesses
and he did very well he's a leading
citizen but he never learned to read and
write it he'd never learned in Europe I
didn't find that out too late for my
mother died he was kind of a family hero
we're used I say were you surprised I
was surprised to learn that three
million 250,000 that's the biggest
number in that hundred years the biggest
number of from any one place except for
Germany editing that came to the United
States austria-hungary had three million
or so and we'll show you that in just a
moment were you surprised that so many I
think so yeah then you have the inset
here was the numbers on in Europe
primarily ad for actually there's a
couple bigger numbers yet they are the
Irish it four million four hundred
thousand it 2,500,000 from England
at 3 million seven hundred thousand from
Austria Hungary and then you show
130,000 from Spain it's interesting also
and I talked about that it looks to know
why they came I mean there were you know
be the potato famine brought the Irish
and out of famine what brought a lot of
the Italians and pretty clean Sicily I
have a chapter I have a couple pages on
Sicily and why people left their and/or
you find times of persecution it German
Germany had a freedom revolution that
failed and a lot of people fled its I
mean their reasons for immigration and
of course the map right now or the
recent immigration would be totally
different chapter 8 of this book
presidents again this first line notice
colon this chapter may be boring why do
you say that well when you have to learn
list of presidents or a list of states
it's boring so I'm in rmc you see happen
however he says it yeah now there is
something you can do about it you can
skip it however be where some of the
information this chapter is important so
if you skip it you do it at your own
risk you might not get a good grade on a
test kids so you you better learn these
presidents like it or not let's see what
else I can find here then you go back to
your family here I found at the end you
show Isaac Ginsburg in the back hall
when you go around how often you find
the kids interested in your own
background um I find them I haven't
gotten much I find adults were more
interested in that some reason I haven't
had kids I I tell them my my middle name
in the beginning a book on several kids
you know I've commented on that they
feel like they know something that pizza
and your middle name is Natalie which is
which is my granddaughter's name somehow
they like to ask me about that but they
don't ask me about my grandfather all
right here is a very strong statement on
your part great leaders have the ability
to inspire people they can make people
do what they wish them to do Woodrow
Wilson was a great leader
there are different theories of history
and some people think that leadership it
is what makes the difference others
don't go with that theory I've the more
I read history the more I think leaders
make all the difference in the world and
and you don't shy away from telling
people who you think we're great leaders
right right but I constantly say you
don't have to agree with me kids who was
a bad leader you say that ah well I mean
Harding has some reason I don't know
yeah sure here that list of presidents
is is very frank here's another note
from an offer from another one of your
boutonniere never getting near the end
of all the books and you're talking
about the bomb and you say wisdom and
foolishness in modern times you bet and
sometimes it was hard to tell them apart
should the bomb have been dropped the
answer was obvious of course not it was
outrageous and barbaric to bomb children
and other civilians with any kind of
bomb the bombs dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki where the terrible outcome of a
misguided idea then he'd jump down and
says but there was another question that
had to be asked what would you have done
if you were her Harry Truman if you had
a weapon that would end the war quickly
and save lives on both sides would you
have used it of course you would in 1945
hardly anyone even thought of hesitating
yeah I think what's what schools do and
I really think we need to get away from
this is teach children that there's one
correct answer to every question and and
that's just not true when the
interesting questions have multiple
answers and our difficulty you know that
decision to drop the bomb was wrenching
it was and we're going to argue forever
on whether it should be done and we just
can't have a pat answer we need to
examine the issues and struggle with
them and that's what I try and get kids
to understand the hardback book of all
this is this book called freedom a
history of us when did you do this what
did you actually write this last year
fairly quickly that that's an adult
version it's I'm hoping that'll be used
in high schools it's for families and
that goes with the television series it
has 16 parts just as the Batavian series
has 16 parts it's a little more
sophisticated it gets away from the the
tone of
that I use in the history of us in what
way does it get away from the tone it um
well there is a certain parental or two
you know where I'm telling you this is
this is what I think this is what you
you know that you use when you talk to
kids this is much which is more like an
adult book how did the television series
come to pass and there's not Peter Quinn
heart who's the producer of the
television series found the the original
history books and decided he wanted to
do a series based on it and then when
you have a television series you need a
companion book so that's how this this
book evolved and also we'd had a lot of
requests for one volume a one-volume
history of us so that's what this is one
of the stories in this book that got my
attention was also on the other book is
The Strange Case of the Chinese Laundry
in San Francisco yo what's the store I
yo was a a Chinese light it right after
the during the gold rush you know a lot
of a lot of men came out to San
Francisco without any women they needed
to have their clothes washed and so
there were a lot of laundries that came
up it was a jerry-built town the
laundries were in wooden buildings they
used fire and you didn't want fires in
san francisco so law was passed saying
no laundries in wooden buildings but it
was only enforced the only built the
only laundries that were closed down
were Chinese laundries and so the
Chinese protested and went to court and
said that they shouldn't be treated any
differently than anyone else there was
another issue the Chinese weren't
citizens because they couldn't be
according to law they couldn't be
citizens and we had discriminatory laws
and it went all the way to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court's a really
important case said that aliens have the
same rights as American citizens and
should be treated the same way and this
is this is a case that's used as
president now for a lot when Mexicans
coming over they have the same legal
rights as aliens as American citizens
and as you know the closer you get to
the present time
the stronger views are from a lot of
people yeah and let me just read what
you say about Bill Clinton you say Bill
Clinton turns out to be the most
conservative Democrat president
Democratic president since Grover
Cleveland he cuts welfare puts more
police on the streets bills prison steps
up the war on drugs expands the death
penalty and after a passage of deficit
reduction bill with no Republican
support balances the budget you did
choose words like that when you're
writing about present time carefully I
do why why would nobody seems to care a
whole lot of heroin what happened 100
years ago when you get into the into the
current threat you know recent
presidents they do care but you then
wrote later on yet Clinton's presidency
begun with promise turns into a
political and national disaster he's
investigated by a special prosecutor he
lies about his personal behavior and in
1998 is impeached in the House of
Representatives and tried in the Senate
where he has found not guilty of high
crimes and misdemeanors but the entire
process which focuses on his
relationship with a young woman who
worked as an intern in the White House
is intensely partisan expensive
distracting and humiliating for the
entire country how long did it take you
to write that paragraph no I did a lot
of thinking about were you walking a
fine line or you know I mean yeah I mean
um did you have personal strong feelings
about Bill Clinton one way or the other
I think that I was enormously
disappointed and what you know this a
man with such potential who mucked up
big time and what it went and we all
paid a price pride in it how terrible
disgraceful uh in the end what are your
do you have strong political views
yourself um I I try very hard to I guess
most people to to I think we need
conservatism when we need liberalism and
I try not to be knee-jerk anything I
writing editorials for a newspaper made
me think carefully about my opinions
lots of ideas that I had when I was
speaking to friends when I had to
actually justify them on paper
I suppose I became more conservative
than I thought I was but I certainly
have I I'd like to think that I combine
the best well I'd like to combine
liberalism and conservatism and I think
that an imbalance is not good for our
country when you when you talk about the
l word is if it's something evil it's
nonsense so how do you do all this what
do you mean I mean there's 2073 pages if
you wrote Plus this hard back here I
mean air you're fast writer um I'm
fairly efficient I guess and where do
you write it where'd you write all this
i sat down i write every day from nine
o'clock to loom he's amazing if you
write every day you know i have a
schedule and i'm right now I've got
three books on science written that I'm
anxious to get out there and we don't
know science I mean the science under la
eyes are times all the goodies that you
and I enjoy the computers and the fax
machines it's that's quantum theory most
people don't know what that is and and
how it came about and then the
personalities that brought it to us and
that's fun so yeah I just I just don't
like to satisfy my curiosity in writing
and you say you're not a historian and
you approach this as a journalist right
again what's the difference well and I
think that's it's um I see a journalist
as a snoop a questioner as somebody who
wants to learn and the 20th century was
a time of specialization and journalists
dive into any subject as a journalist
you know I've written about all kinds of
things and you have to learn and you
have to you have to learn to look for
experts and to ask the right questions
and that's what I attempt to do and
that's what our kids need to do and I
think in our teachers too many of them
are afraid of subjects I've had teachers
come up to me and say oh I'm really
scared of teaching history cuz I don't
know any history I said that's okay
learn it with your kids we you know we
need to be open to learning so where are
we in this country when it comes to kids
learning history compared to what it was
50 years ago 50 years ago history was
central to the curriculum it's it's it's
very much peripheral now and it needs to
be central at the first of all it's a
great mother disciplined everything is
Street everything that happened
yesterday in before is history so it's a
way to tie Ric EULA together new art
music poetry baseball everything is
history and you can make the links and
it's its connections that make learning
exciting so we need to we need to really
concentrate on history as a way to teach
reading thinking I mean history gives
you ideas to to think about that we've
neglected it at our peril besides the
idea that as citizens if we don't know
who we are we can't be effective
citizens our guest is the author of this
10 volume series it looks like this book
right here called a history of us and
also this hardback which you can find in
your book stores called freedom of
history of us a one-volume series a
companion to the PBS program that has
been airing the first part of the year
on your PBS stations our guest has been
joy hakem and we thank you very much for
joining us thank you for having me